[Music]
school everybody's Lord marching here
from Lourdes gaming dotnet I'm here with
Shelly from toga productions the PR
manager studio here we're going to talk
about coffee talk so how's it going
getting a reception from the games are
you bringing out getting reception of
the games bringing out like coffee talk
perfect perfect so we're gonna talk
about coffee talk we've briefly
mentioned whatever eyes which was to say
coffee brewing similarly are you talking
to people on about their problems you
helping them through it so talk a little
more about the game or players to
inspect from in this interview become a
barista
so you serve warm drinks to the
customers and then they will unveil
their stories also it's a deciding it's
a fantasy so you can meet lots of races
like werewolves vampire even fish kins
so what's the inspiration behind
bringing a fantasy element to this game
oh it's actually we cover some sensitive
issues yeah so it's to to make it not
too subtle yeah
so we choose the fantasy type thing all
right perfect now we talk a little about
the game let's actually break down what
when the player is going through here so
talk a little bit about what's going on
on screen oh it's the opening screen
actually it's where coffee table is
located so coffee table is actually a
cafe in a Seattle so we which is yellow
as the
please nice character designs and art
itself it's just it stands out it pops
so who's behind the animation behind the
art saw behind this game
the art is Yamaha yeah perfect perfect
so whether it's are we getting like
different spins on the werewolves or the
fantasy monsters sure but the the
product main protagonist here is human
okay so what kind of options are a
dialogue options I've got players in the
go through so the different thing in
cafetalk is we actually don't choose the
dialogue but we surf drink so the drinks
will what is it will affect the
branching system the branching the story
branching oh cool so it's so you see
here the players choosing different
ingredients it looks like and all that
will affect the dialogue itself you're
saying right yeah okay perfect so what
coffee coffee
it's enthusiastic kind of game what can
players looking at coffee and fish and
ADO's expect from coffee talk sorry well
can't coffee and fish now is expect from
coffee talk like will you guys do your
research on this game for coffee yeah
actually the game designer is a toffee
aficionado so he he knows a lot about
coffee actually and then yeah he's like
he wants to bring the what is it the
feeling of town after drinking coffee in
a cafe
yet right right because because really
coffee is kind of like the icebreaker
right whether it's for a day or even
you're just hanging out with somebody
it's always a nice good mediation
between two people and just connecting
each other so it's everywhere you're
trying to go forward this game where you
have different characters and he's
really trying to break down the core of
a person actually yeah yeah it's the
feeling of calmness we want to project
so what do we want people to experience
in this game is more connectivity with
people and it's having kind of like that
like it's nice relaxed and chill game
and they feel like maybe relatable with
the characters with their problems
perfect so how long can players are how
long it's a playthrough of coffee talk
have you guys gone through it already or
is it like a good 510 our experience or
four to six maybe six if you play it
again because it's it has the replay
value the Ryoka the replay of it so you
get more out of if you just keep you
playing and go through the different
options yeah because there are many
endings many different endings there
well then we talked a lot about coffee
talk wanking players like to play it
right now because it's already out steam
ps4 Xbox in then the switch and you name
it all right well you heard it here on
Lords of gaming that Nets Lord watches
signing up thanks for tuning in
you
[Music]